[Musique]
ils ont un petit air de caravane du tour
mais ces trois triporteurs et leurs
pilotes sentent en mission quasi
évangéliques pour redonner le goût de la
lecture à ceux qui d'habitude fui les
bibliothèques
l'idée c'est d'aller au devant du public
a vraiment de donner accès à la culture
au plus grand nombre et pas seulement
ceux qui rentrent dans les bibliothèques
mais ceux justement qui n'y vont pas et
puis c'est aussi un moyen pour nous
d'aller au devant des bibliothèques du
territoire du loiret de les valoriser de
travailler avec elle dans le ciel les
oiseaux consterné tournoi y est en nuage
qui s'abattait de nouveaux prenaient
leur envol
ainsi parlait robert louis stevenson
l'auteur de l'île aux trésors qui
parcourut le loiret à pied en 1875 et en
tire à ce récit de voyage cette anecdote
et beaucoup d'autres vous seront contées
cette semaine par des bibliothécaires
des artistes et des bénévoles
ils s'associent pour remonter le
parcours de la loire à vélo en amenant
les livres sur les places de village ou
au bord du fleuve
partout où la rencontre entre livres et
public peut avoir lieu sans frein il est
nécessaire que la culture ne soit pas
centré sur des métropoles centrée sur
des communautés de communes mais puisse
aller en territoire cette lecture si on
veut qu'elle vive et qu'elle soit pas
une histoire d'élite et bien nous
allions porter voilà avec nos triporteur
des livres qui sont distribués données
et puis qui provoque des animations
c'est la première tournée des
triporteurs baptisé biblio cycle est si
l'expérience est concluante elle se
reproduire à chaque été dans le loiret